the flag at half-mast outside a moving
remembrance inside four days after the
bloody attacks in Paris the French
national anthem rang out in the European
Parliament little toddy pavia teen
attack on to not a Liberty in attack
antonova loyal European he not a model
almost all any peas were present
speaking in the prison's of alum this
year the French Secretary of State for
European affairs federica mogherini the
EU foreign affairs chief jean-claude
Juncker the President of the European
Commission marching shoes stressed
solidarity with France Donna douloureux
new era para samsung cote de pablo
francais nous sommes in a risky jame
newly tiempo de fondo not a modded avi
einat associated after President Schultz
also warned against mistaking the enemy
see no suspect 0 to let a few jada city
alone Oh confound our victim mr pierre
no no less a home pasamos oniy polovina
basically be there for days on from the
attacks in Paris Emma piece from all
political flanks of the Brussels Emma
cycle remain united it remains to be
seen whether such solidarity will be
seen in the Strasburg than a recession
next week